plusieurs associations rassemblées pour
un seul message
nous n'accepterons pas que l'avion
puisse débarquer des gens ici voilà ce
samedi 29 février un avion en provenance
de milan devrait atterrir à l'aéroport
aimé césaire à son bord des passagers en
transit ou effectuer une croisière dans
les caraïbes
seulement voilà en italie le coronavirus
est déjà à l'origine de 11 décès environ
320 personnes sont infectées dans le
pays
ce matin plusieurs associations se sont
rassemblés devant l'aéroport aimé
césaire pour dire non à l'atterrissage
de cet appareil et aux risques encourus
le ministère de la santé a dit aux
français de ne pas aller en italie
on ne comprend pas cette logique qui est
que de prendre des risques et il me
semble que le principe de précaution
doit s'appliquer et donc nous s'ils ne
l'appliquent pas de l'appliquer nous
mêmes nous sommes des personnes humaines
et c'est ce qui prime c'est à dire le
droit à la vie le droit au respect des
fondements mêmes qui font que nous
sommes là nous sommes des martiniquais
et que nous droit en tant que personne
humaine doivent être respectées si ces
gens là ne voyage pas qu'est ce qui se
passe rien j'ai pas de croisière puisque
tout ça me dit qu est ce qu un moment
donné un moment de détente et de plaisir
superficielle doit prévaloir sur
l'essentiel qui est la vie
avant de rejoindre le mouvement ce matin
au siège de la sopam à plusieurs membres
de l'association se sont réunis pour la
rédaction d'un courrier adressé aux
autorités demandant l'annulation du vol
la soupe a marre tout comme d'autres
associations interpellent des
martiniquais d'ici samedi nous mettrons
aussi tout en brun nous appellons donc
les martiniquais pour empêcher donc
l'atterrissage de cet avion dont un en
martinique des mouvements déjà réfléchi
et des associations ont déjà pris
contact aussi donc avec l'unss obama
pour qu'on puisse bien sûr à voir donc
des actions convergentes pour que ce
fait respecter dans ce pays ce matin
dans un courrier adressé au premier
ministre edouard philippe
le député de la martinique serge
letchimy a demandé je cite que ce vol en
provenance de milan soit reporté ou
annulé